all right so i was reading about how
this film feeling a little bit like a
piece of theater was very appealing to
you so is there anything about working
in that sort of stripped-down
environment that i don't know even after
all these years had you discovering
something new about your craft that
you're eager to apply on future films oh
absolutely i mean i'd come off the back
of thor and avengers and uh
extraction and so you know a lot of
big special effects and and uh and
action which i love and it's fun and
fantastic but i really wanted to do
something smaller and more contained and
character driven and just focused on uh
you know the individuals within this
space and it was right through sort of
covered restrictions and so on so if we
were going to make a film it had to be
contained and the opportunity came up to
make this film and we shot it in i think
about four weeks um on two or three sets
in one safe contained environment and it
was so much fun it was so much fun i
mean it looks pretty intense and the the
thoughts that this movie put in my mind
are uh you know a little disturbing but
i imagine you did have fun
we don't necessarily need this in the
movie but i do tend to get a little
obsessed with backstory information on
very curious characters so it was making
me wonder is there any backstory details
that you came up with that maybe we
don't see or hear in the film but are
heavily informing you know the way he
carries himself and the decision-making
process he goes through yeah i think
that he's an individual who um
a complex individual a huge ego highly
intelligent
void of the ability to feel empathy i
think to an extent and
lack of social etiquette
um whether that had to do with his sort
of you know inner chemical makeup or
whether it was to do with his childhood
he's up to the interpretation of an
audience um
you know there's sort of there is a
little hint at his childhood and the
fact that there was a real
um
lack of of
emotional connection and love and
support that we all need um
and so i do think that you know his
experiences as a young child has led him
to a place of uh well led him to this
place where
he's trying to fill in the blanks i
guess and and try to you know make up
for what he feels is missing in his his
emotional personal personality and his
up i don't know maybe a prequel would be
even more disturbing than this film
the bemidji could be
so i was reading a quote from joseph in
the press notes about how the ensemble
in this movie really raised each other's
game so given how many scenes you share
with miles is there anything about him
as a scene partner that you really
appreciated and maybe helped you tap
into something in your own character
that you wouldn't have been able to
reach without him yeah definitely um
he has such a fun sense of humor and
there's a sort of cheekiness to him
which um
which kind of made me feel like i was
back in high school and we're kind of
doing something silly and wrong and and
um
and the film has that quality there's an
unpredictable sort of odd uh
suspense that plays out through the film
and so
you know we were playing one emotion and
one idea yet we were sort of trying to
stifle and hold something else aside
i think that comes through um and and
and and it was great and he's a great
collaborator collaborator um
incredibly talented you know quite an
intensity to him too but he can be
vulnerable in the on
on on
on a dime so yeah he's a lot of fun and
journey to my left too had did a lot of
scenes with miles and then started
working with journey in one scene and
instantly it kind of
shifted my perspective and how i was
playing that particular scene which is
what you want you know you don't want to
you come in with a set of ideas and you
hope people are going to surprise you
and redirect you into space it's cool
she has something else i'll end on a
semi-silly one we play a filmmaking
would you rather game all the time and
the scene with the g46 and the laughing
made me think of this one would you
rather have to fake laugh in a scene or
fake cry in a scene
why
i'd say
i'd say fake fake laugh because the
byproduct of that is usually joy and you
feel pretty good afterwards
the fake crying can be you know you
occasionally got to dig into something
you might not want to have a have a
think about to sort of drum up some of
that emotion so you and miles are on the
same wavelength he went for the same
thing
good
all right thanks for your time today
congratulations thank you very much
you